he found out very quickly that when you
put 135 pounds over your head your
shoulder goes out when you're 60 years
old and that was a pretty rough time
frame hi I'm Troy
hi I'm the way Oh Jeremy we're gym
employees yeah so let's do it
what's the biggest complaint you get the
biggest complaint I get is that the
locker room is dirty yeah that's
probably like a big one that I get -
yeah yeah yeah empty out the towels
there so the toilet I'd say the biggest
complaints we get are we have a specific
program like people program to work out
and it's always gonna be somebody who
doesn't like what we're programming too
many squats too many there's a man
running around naked there's a guy
flossing and between himself drying
himself at the counter mostly it has to
do with the locker room in the claim
right like the biggest and a good one is
this guy he's single out on the bed with
his headphones they're telling the
content and it's on the decoy yeah no
yeah the biggest complaint I get is the
bathrooms they come up to me especially
on weekends when we're lower staff they
come up to me like they expect me to go
clean the women's restroom but that's
not what I'm here for
how often is the equipment cleaned when
I work I always I work twice a week so I
could say at least twice a week that I
wipe down everything at the end of the
night so I make sure that everything's
close to my knowledge every might every
night we do this it's definitely
dependent on the staff at that locations
for the gym that I work it in one
location
I worked weekdays so I saw the people
who took pride in maintaining our
building and facilities now where I work
because I mostly work weekends I don't
really see the cleaning crew as often so
it just really depends on your location
and honestly what do you think of people
taking selfies on machines look don't
don't hate me and unlike that but I
think you're super lame but I understand
you gotta get your lights up if you have
no pictures you wasn't it
I understand the bus lanes up I hate it
I hate it so much whenever I do go to
like
gyms and you'll see the guys that are
like at the machine and their life
taking their pictures or they're like
hey get a picture of me real quick
doing this machine trying to flex I hate
it so much it's my favorite walking into
the men's locker room and you see all
these guys standing in front of the
mirror taking pictures and then as soon
as they see you they like want to act
like they were doing something else and
it's like you just capture it's like
it's okay like just keep doing and you
know you're sent ristic narcissistic way
isn't like that's totally fine but like
he's going definitely put your damn
phone in your locker and just work out
or get off the machine because somebody
else needs to use it I endorse it I
understand it I mean because eventually
I'm getting my trainer and certificate
my training certificate so I need to
post about my workout if you get a
movement or something like that you like
a heavy clean you want to be like Oh
record this something like that you know
report because you you know you just you
just got a a new personal best that's
fine post up oh but it does I do notice
and I'd be like that person over there
my favorite part of working at the gym
and least favorite part my favorite part
of working at the gym is we have a
really good community and my gym and a
lot of us all hang out together after
classes people would just hang out talk
we will grab food a lot of times I'd say
my least favorite part would be I hate
cleaning the floors up getting favorite
part of working at the gym is free
membership yeah thank you every members
use that's the way definitely there's
definitely the best part I agree
like the bond between the members and
even some of the other employees became
more family like here my least favorite
part are the complainers and and then
people with it like la attitudes if they
don't talk much and then I will save my
least favorite thing it's in everybody
every single day and that fake how you
doing yeah how's it going like or
working out at that gym because when you
work at a gym and you work out there it
doesn't matter if you have headphones on
it doesn't matter if you're in the
middle
set it doesn't matter if you're on a
Stairmaster they will come up to you hey
can you take care of this ray can you
talk to me about my account that's
annoying so like if you are out there
don't annoy the people that work at a
gym that are working out because then we
just charge you for you it just says
getting freaky in the sauna
question mark well we don't have a song
at my gym so that's it easy yes yes I
can yes you've had to kick those people
out and usually it's from another member
they'll come up to you and they'll tell
you like hey I just want to let you know
that there's some things that I thought
were inappropriate and they won't
directly say what's going on but they'll
allude to it by either motion and of
course you got to go break the news to
me kick them out I have not known as
people or caught people or anything I
think it's very dangerous if you were to
try that have you ever hooked up with
someone while working no I'm sure I have
no nah man I haven't either
I try to keep everything separate do you
work out more or less frequently since
you started working huh
more or less it's annoying when people
come to the gym and then you want to
work out and then they see that you work
there and they want to ask you all the
questions so you don't really get a good
workout in when that happens and then
you just get sick of going to the same
place I'd say I've worked more since
I've started working there because now I
have the keys to the gym so if I miss
like a class or something like that I
could just go open up and I live maybe
like five minute walk away from my gym
so I could just walk over there and
the reason why we got more than not I
got a membership is because first off I
gotta pay for a second though I gotta
stay in shape I got a feel getting
knocked out and I don't ever want to get
knocked out so I got to make sure I'm
straight - I don't get knocked out okay
I would say I work out a lot more since
I work at the gym it's a perk having
free memberships I can go to any
education any state how many injuries do
you see on a given day I hurt myself a
few times and I don't cross it we get a
bad rap and people get hurt that's just
people who come in there try to be the
Hulk or whatever it don't listen to
their bodies or to themselves but I get
nicked up every now and again but that's
because I'm not very many
most people that like us to work out
consistently know what they're doing and
if you do see injuries it might be like
I need a band-aid or can you stretch me
out because I'm worried about my
hamstrings but then it might not
necessarily be an injury I've never seen
anybody get injured at the gym that I
work at I have gotten several requests
for band-aids if they like accidentally
scratch up against something or there's
a basketball court people have nails I
never needed major injuries one of my
presidency a couple months ago now we
were doing burpees and she was trying to
go too fast you know foot got caught in
the ground so she fractured her foot so
that was probably the last injury and me
I see none
I see no injuries at all close my eyes
any time I hear about him I hear people
screaming from injuries but my eyes
never lady sight on injuries at all
what's the worst injury you ever seen it
work same thing just the cut separated
shoulder had a guy was six years old
maybe around there and he thought he
could step into a CrossFit class and do
the same things that he did when he was
20 he found out very quickly that when
you put 135 pounds of your head your
shoulder goes out when you're 16 years
old and that was a pretty rough time
doing box jumps I've seen also myself
you you slip and get a nice little
scrape on your shin I've never had it
before I never seen the injury before
because if I found out somebody get hurt
I instantly go lock myself in the room
and I'm
but ambulance got them out of their
homes injuries at all no what is the
strange thing someone had left at the
gym locker room usually it just be like
people leave their wrist straps or jump
rope or so nothing nothing crazy my
members are weirdos then because they
maybe even keys wallets debit cards
water bottles swimsuits they believe in
everything for me I would say cocaine
cocoa for me I'd say dildos that's
interesting but you wonder like what
they were doing with their wealth or
their that's kind of just like my idea
naturally how did this work is it a leg
day oh my and I would say like syringes
I live in Hollywood I work in Hollywood
so it's a lot going on syringes man keep
them clean please I don't know if that's
strange to me I feel like that's like an
occupational hazard to have a better gym
it's just like you're gonna see needles
- I'm disappointed about the questions
will be harder they didn't make me think
no I'm just playing had a lot of fun
answering y'all's questions these are
some cool interesting questions
definitely eye-opening that I want to
know these things so I hope I answered
them I hope we yeah like hopefully we
answered all of them and if you have
more drop them into the comments right
under here yeah I remember we'll get it
taken carefully and answer it
that's
[Music]